so you guys shot this October back in
2015
did you know each other had you ever
come across each other but no no we
hadn't Wow I was super excited to be
able to work with her yeah big fan and I
was very exciting and I think the end of
the first day shooting I was sitting
with Jon Hamm and I said have you got it
clear are you believing that you and I
are Geena Davis is parents Lois I'm
fascinated by the timeline of your
involvement with this whole project I
mean it's it's based on a play by Jordan
Harrison you performed it here in LA
then you did this film in the adaptation
by Michael Morita and then you perform
the play again in New York after doing
the movie yes now given the fact that
you went from technically Jordan's
writing to Michael's writing to Jordan's
writing again since the screenplay is
Michael's did you have to learn and
unlearn things when you went back to do
the play again very little
marjorie's role probably more than any
others is more the same in the film as
the play there's less text some
rewriting but most of the rewriting took
place with the other characters so it
was I was very much at home who had been
living with this text for years actually
since I was first given the play so what
was it life and having done the film to
then do the the play again oh no it's an
app as far as I know a unique journey
which I never had before and don't ever
expect to have again but it was a great
privilege to go through all of this it
was a new yet a new director at one
point Jordan said to me Oh Louis what
what a thing for you to work with with
four directors I said Jordan I thought
it was three and he said I'm counting
Pam MacKinnon because it was Pam who
first gave me the script that they both
were
that club from a writer's development
organization in New York City and when
it was brand-new
pam-pam sent it to me and we read it for
Jordan first and then you know it went
on its journey but when the first
production at the taper came Pam had a
conflict with her Broadway place she was
doing that year so then director number
2 les waters came in michael la mirada
was the third third and then and Kaufman
in New York right so it was four what
are your recollections of the shoot I
mean these are scenes that are 10 11 12
pages in some cases I would imagine this
was not a luxuriously long shoot what
are your recollections of having of the
challenges of the day well that was one
of the big challenges but also really
fun I mean an actor wants to have meaty
thing is to do and and feel challenged
and and it was very fast we've been
trying to remember how many actual
shooting days it was but it was probably
in the teens and and so yeah you'd you
know do some very intense emotional
scene one day and then okay what's
tomorrow
oh the 12-page scene that's tomorrow so
it was very challenging but you know
felt like the power on this fun thing
together did you guys talk to each other
and with John since all three of you
play Prime's at some point in the film
about making your performances as primes
similar in any way since I would imagine
it was the same technology and the same
company making these making all three of
the primes did you guys talk to each
other about how those performances would
be or did you just let it happen never
talked about it did you oh I forgot to
that would have prevented you like to
talk about it I think it was that's okay
because we played Prime's at different
stages of their development like mine
was day one and and fresh out of the box
we always fresh out of the box right is
it at all intimidating
to come on to a project when one of the
cast members has done it already were
you feeling like oh my gosh how can we
catch up to Oh
or is that the joy of it to work with
someone who's inhabited the character
for a long time we found it we all found
it fascinating and we would ask
questions like this Louis to do is it
different thing I don't know none of it
was that fascinating to Louis you know
in this movie I think has a lot to say
about loss about grief can you guys talk
a little bit about what you think this
film adds to that conversation and what
intrigued you about it I don't know if
I've ever seen a piece that was so
deeply about memory and and it's what it
is how we make it how we use it how we
deal with it I and it's all it's also
tied into people and their relationships
that I know I'm just babbling but I
guess that's for me the depth the the
center seed of it yeah mm-hmm yeah I
think so too it's about how memory
changes us and mutates and and how
important it is to us but but also how
it changes in hand and frankly how
artificial intelligence might play a
role in that in the future in the near
future I mean this is pretty much almost
possible at this point but I know I was
very disturbed you know I have a scene
where I talk about the the theory behind
memory that it's a copy of a copy you
know that that you're just remembering
your memory and I was very unhappy to
learn that and I'm not sure that I want
to subscribe to that because I don't
like it I sort of wish it wasn't brought
up
but it's too late well it's such a
pleasure to see both of you so thank you
very much for being here Geena Davis and
Lois Smith everybody